zu abend essen sie ist zu abend sie hat
zu haben
gegessen das geschenk öffnen
sie öffnet das geschenk sie hat das
geschenk geöffnet mit dem flugzeug
fliegen
er fliegt mit dem flugzeug
er ist mit dem flugzeug geflogen
im supermarkt einkaufen
sie kauft im supermarkt ein
sie hat dem supermarkt eingekauft
im pool schwimmen
er schwimmt im pool
er ist im pool geschwommen dem boden
putzen
er putzt den boden
er hat den boden geputzt nach hause
gehen
er geht nach hause er ist nach hause
gegangen
die zeitung lesen
er liest die zeitung
er hat die zeitung gelesen
die teller abwaschen
er wäscht die täler ab er hat die teller
abgewaschen über politik streiten
er streitet über politik er hat über
politik gestritten
ein bier trinken
er trinkt ein bier
er hat ein bier getrunken
auf dem laufband rennen sie rennt auf
dem laufband
[Musik]
sie ist auf dem laufband gerannt